this 165 000 square foot Warehouse is
piled high with liquidated Goods
including the never-ending stream of
things we've all been returning
liquidation company quicklots estimates
that about 30 percent of the products it
receives are clearly used returns a
little charger watch this is like a very
expensive Swiss watch of course
underwear customer returns are
skyrocketing filling landfills and
warehouses like this one to the brim
about like this we estimate to be about
twenty thirty thousand dollars in retail
value so how did it all get here and how
are retailers feeling the impact of an
increasing number of unwanted Goods
and that pair of pants you bought online
doesn't fit quite right the solution is
easy return it and get a refund but
after you mail them back where those
pants end up is a bit more complicated
the best of all possible answers is that
the good gets repackaged and goes back
on the Shelf so it's ready for sale as a
new item but getting there is costly
reverse logistics company operator
estimates that on average it costs 66
percent of the price of an item to
process its return for example if those
pants you returned were fifty dollars it
would cost the retailer 33 dollars to
take them back
so many returns travel through a
complicated web of warehouses secondary
resellers and landfills first up is a
returns processing center where the item
gets inspected for damage every company
has a different set of standards for
what can be repackaged and sold again
and plenty of things don't meet them
optoro says that many retailers threw
away over a quarter of returned Goods in
2019. the amount of returns in excess
inventory that retailers send to
landfills has more than doubled since
2016. from 4 billion pounds to 9.6
billion pounds but everything else is
harder to track the rest of the unwanted
Goods filter through our secondary
resale Market including retailer outlets
and Online Auctions One path leads to
liquidation companies like quick lots
retailers their business is to retail
their business is not to deal with
rejected inventory they figure out how
to just streamline the process by
liquidating
companies like Nordstrom Target and Best
Buy send products by the truck full
those trucks are filled with pallets of
both customer returns and excess
inventory or items that never sold in
the first place everything comes bundled
together as liquidation and a lot of
times if you merchandise that are brand
new they could have been returns but
they're hard to identify because they
got returned with tags in in a brand new
condition the company sells pallets
wholesale but it also sorts their items
by category and condition its clients
are other resellers from people listing
on marketplaces like eBay or Poshmark to
Mom and Pop discount stores to flea
market stands and now companies are
dealing with even more returns according
to the National Retail Federation
customer returns across the retail
industry are growing as e-commerce sales
explode online returns do too they've
more than doubled in the past few years
from 9.6 in 2019 to 20.8 in 2021. so
when we shop at a store we see feel
smell we know what we're getting when we
shop online we don't have that sensation
and so we end up buying more items so
that we can see feel smell touch them
retailers themselves have made it easier
with long return windows and free
shipping those policies that especially
Amazon created years ago has increased
that convenience to the customer and
because one retailer started everybody
has to follow suit emling says retailers
would rather eat the cost of returns
than disappoint customers but at the end
of the day returns still affect
consumers those costs go into the price
that they charge for items and
ultimately that cost is borne by us
for retailers overwhelmed with return
Goods offloading them to Liquidators can
be a relief
it's a painful process and they just
want to get rid of it they just want
someone else to do it and it can be a
way to recoup some loss emling says if
retailers think that those goods will
end up in a landfill selling them to
Liquidators instead can be an appealing
Choice still returns eat into the bottom
line retail isn't a high margin business
and a large part of that are all of the
costs that go in to
things like returns that is actively
cutting in to the margins that retailers
make but it's tricky to track the actual
cost the responsibility is diffused
among different groups within the
organization too many companies are not
measuring the cost that they're spending
on reverse Logistics
as returns increase some retailers are
changing their policies but it's not
widespread companies that are selling
Goods that can be found on other
websites are going to find it much more
difficult because if I can find the same
product somewhere else and it's free
returns that's where I'm going but
despite making small shifts ambling says
retailers aren't prioritizing dealing
with returned items right now consumers
have no idea what happens to a return
once they let's say drop it off at a at
a UPS Store once that becomes
transparent
they will change
[Music]